now the people are released which there
is no good solution we need to build
indexes France is fractured its economy
stagnating and it's social fabric is
falling apart so this year's
presidential election is being fueled by
fear on all sides across kalila Caesar
is also terrible physically definite
unitary economic 2017
he who can afford it the passage before
her failed and we are still a lot of
problems a lot of unemployment so I
think people are fed up with that we
always said in the tents of defense for
the past - you choose and founded of the
compound new eliminate they don't go and
booth it can can automatically give more
more good motivates of a marine lepen
marine lepen
a level of rock acidity sir relevant
more proposes issues even on folk
binoculars horses have already seen
people going on the street and playing
that thing to a black people black man
or saying some insults and that's
something I never saw before so it's
like a now I'm authorized to do so and
just like President Donald Trump marine
lepen is using economic anxiety and
racial resentment against Muslims and
immigrants to rally her base violence
against Jews and France has doubled in
the past year you don't see a
correlation between the rise of Lipan
and upon national and those divisions in
society and hate crime
so mirc constant political assisted
digital who is suspected
yes co-prophet only see the remote view
or newtonís also present a new professor
through the years across a family
lovingly shot al yep a decisive special
so then who do you blame for all these
divisions and this rise in hate crimes
against Muslims against you who do you
blame an opportunity for seminary campus
this is a needle images a song or
photography the opportunities in
curriculum all those white people to be
seated in chief action-masala working on
it I can go in here makes it a
resistance a vote for the centrist
candidate in Manuel Macomb who's backed
by mainstream parties may seem obvious
in the face of what many here call the
fascist threat but just as glue see one
of three young women who share the same
struggles but have reached different
decisions told me you can't fight
fascism by voting for the man who
symbolizes the very neoliberalism that
drove people to demand radical change if
you don't go on make them isn't that
gonna increase to ten percent maybe but
I I'm scared that my penguin I'm scared
that human it's the choice between two
bad solutions I can't vote for the
capitalism I can't vote for the passion
almost one-quarter of French voters are
sane during the first round of elections
in April and at least one out of four
citizens are expected to abstain in the
upcoming vote in fact macron is what is
the capitalism
the very big advantage is the bank and
what is the power of capital is it
cookies before anyway it's a kind of
fascist capitalist for me but like so
many in France
Lucy is simply fed up with political
theater the soccer loss of security
security that don't talk anymore
deliberately
and the tutor said put us in the clear
in the AIDS of the others because there
are a lot of suspicions then you know
how your terror in tonight with your
children
you just olicity first it was people at
half-speed able to get some community
service
the speciality of basically the Sweeney
pilgrim of the four technologies they
accept the agency proposal she said it's
the vulture yes it's the fault of the
immigrants the foreigners and all that I
think that is a mistake to believe that
he has real ethical volatility absolute
work to release the living a tool of
security Saluda Baku village
conceptually we go facility already
opposite the vestibule o'clock there may
add a table with the Vilnius like Trump
the pen has perfected the art of
exploiting the fears of her base and
just like Hillary Clinton by Collins
relying on the French fears of fascism
to beat Marines National Front we live
in a time of uncertainty everything is
changing so fast the economy is changing
we will have new jobs tomorrow we don't
have a and I thought the international
spinder happening so many things to so
it can be scary I thought and we don't
know how our future will look like so
that can explain also why the young
generation feel a bit less sometimes me
the main problem is that we don't find
jobs with a sense real we just work from
to make money to earn money enough to
live but we don't find the way to exist
to collapse to capture the clear didn't
a cashier forget the public will elicit
cordial is anything to me
I got no support leo aiolia mr. welcome
deputy but in the end whoever ends up
winning this election will be ruling a
new friends where the fringe is now the
mainstream thanks for watching and make
sure to watch our entire French election
playlist